Charles Davis fresh off of calling the
Cowboys win over the Lions one of my
favorite people in the business NFL
Network compadre and of course Fox
Sports analyst right here on the show
what'd you think of my four down strolls
I liked your four downs and I also am
very excited about hearing the
possibilities to come back from a home's
nickname because what you said was it
felt forced on you it did and I can't
wait to see what people come up with
because this kid he ought to generate a
lot of potential nicknames now Garoppolo
as we know when they did the nickname
contest they couldn't use the winner you
remember what the winner was I I don't I
don't recall Jimmy G's what people were
calling him I hear was it was Jimmy G
starts with an S ends with a day that
was like when I worked at Stanford years
ago they told me that when they changed
the nickname remember they were Stanford
Indians and when they changed the
nickname they opened up to the student
body and the student body came back
because they know the history of the
school and Leland Stanford the whole
thing and voted overwhelmingly for
robber barons we can't use that no just
a robber barons that's good oh I could
end up with Cardinal so I'm eager to
hear that but I like your four downs in
the Rams take I can't wait I mean we're
just having so much fun watching what
they're doing unless you're playing them
if you don't have a dog in the fight
they are a blast to watch I'm going to
stop right here rich but there's
something that I've really been
contemplating that I'm asking a lot of
people they did almost nothing preseason
with their first unit goth didn't make
any throws he's a third-year quarterback
and what was always been the paradigm
yeah I get reps for these kids they got
to get game action they got to do this
girl he didn't play they didn't come out
and stumble around on offense they
didn't come out have a lot of penalties
they didn't come out bog down they put
up points they look sharp right out of
the gate what is Shawn mcvade doing
coaching that team in practice that's
different from around the league because
other people rested their guys and
didn't come out looking like that I'm
not just talking about Talent
I'm just all about being a sharp and as
efficient as they been that's a question
we all need to hone in well
something that I've seen on Twitter
unless I put an asterisk on it normally
but apparently attributed to Andrew
Whitworth their stellar tackle and as
you know offensive linemen are maybe
some of the smartest out there on the
field saying that McVeigh in the Rams
teach football the coaching staff
teaches football they don't coach it
Charles maybe that's a difference maker
because all these guys you know the
smartest football guy I've ever been
around is Marshall Faulk he's like dying
man like you dropped toothpicks on the
floor and he would tell you exactly how
many dropped okay no doubt now it seems
to me this Rams offense everybody knows
how to play everybody's position yeah so
a lot of movement a lot of guys can be
in different spot
you can't just type them here unlike a
lot of colleges where you play left side
you play right side in terms of
receivers and stay that way because they
want to play fast and be efficient but
you're right there's a lot of teaching
and Marshall know and Marshall knew
everybody's position including the
quarterback by the way yes he did oh yes
he did there's and he knew what the
defensive guys would do with any given
call to so he he was a Rain Man savant
when he was playing the game and then
teaching it when you sat down and talked
with him with the Rams and watching what
they're doing there's a lot of that
going on and then you know everybody
talks about adjustments and can we get
to halftime they're adjusting series the
series okay whatever you show them
McVeigh is over there okay his
assistants they're getting it and they
have some foot spa - don't think fake
field goal in a position where they
didn't need it
I mean it's gonna be hard in the end
zone though but it wasn't like oh we had
to have it it was desperate like we're
so confident it will score when we get
the ball again let's just take a shot or
that we won't or that we won't need it
later on down the road right said you
uncork it and you put it on tape for
everybody else to see it don't play well
that's the Rams Charles Davis so were
you were you able to when you were
watching the Cowboys just close your
eyes and see the similarities like Jerry
Jones would say from this past week not
quite not quite was the number one
cowboy sees but I think I know where
he's trying to get to okay but they're
not there they're not there because they
don't have anywhere close to the
receiving corps and the dynamic
making ability of Ezekiel Elliott could
easily be like into Todd Gurley I mean
there those two are two peas in a pod
and they're gonna eat up carries and
catches and deke did that on Sunday with
a 240 total yards but the dot the wide
receiver comparison is it even close
right now no nothing really dynamic out
wide
so Zeke's got to eat up enough carries
and enough ground on first and second
down to make third down you know that
word it drives a little crazy manageable
right so that that can make plays but
the key was they actually made play
Sunday rich you know going into Sunday
they were 8 for 34 on third down for the
season that's why he couldn't get
involved as much people say and he's not
carrying it enough well they can stay on
the field this on Sunday they stayed on
the field more and you saw the end
result Charles Davis here on the Rich
Eisen show best team you've seen threw
for four weeks of calling games on Fox
would be who who best I've seen through
four weeks calling game person you have
outdone yourself Hurston man I thought
it would be Minnesota and Green Bay and
I kind of have to stick there even
though they struggled a little bit right
now because Cowboys winning Sunday
against Detroit you know is a good win
for them
I saw San Francisco I'm still sitting on
Green Bay and Minnesota Minnesota start
two and two last year let's not bury him
yet who do you have this week I've got
Carolina hosting the giant that's big
dude I've got you know what that men in
New York right now yeah I've got Landon
Collins coming up the top of the next
hour you know rich I watched in my tape
yesterday and he played okay look he's a
guy that they're counting on to make a
ton of game changing type plays you know
knocking balls free right creating havoc
blitzing the quarterback he's doing his
part those numbers haven't come out yet
but they will at some point but I'm
telling you that guy was all over the
field especially second half against the
Saints I mean the giant talking in there
as long as they could well what are you
seeing offensively out of the Giants
here who by the way after the Browns
just cracked the 40 point barrier the
Giants now have the longest streak in
the NFL without a 30 point game now with
36
and the concept you know this is a big
gamer sation about whether they stuck
with Eli too long where do you stand on
that subject so far Charles I don't have
a problem with them sticking with Eli
what I saw on tape on Sunday was the
saint saying we're gonna drop and you're
gonna throw it in front of us and you're
gonna live with it
and I meant imagine Studios now rich for
doing doing some work and it always
reminds me of something coach Madden
used to say when you take what the
defense gives you that's fine unless you
need more he said he said you know third
and six and the defense gives you fine
five that doesn't work too well does it
so you've got to find a way to take more
than what they're giving you I think
that's what the Giants are searching for
now because the Saint just backed up and
said here's what you're going to do and
they took the check down they took all
that but they couldn't fashion go the
offense and you can't break out obj
break they've got to find ways to just
go ahead and sometimes force it may be a
little Murphy's Law right if something's
jammed force it it breaks it was gonna
break anyway mmm-hmm Charles Davis here
on the Rich Eisen show and I remember at
the draft a couple years ago Charles you
being a Tennessee god you're like
pounding the table for Alvin camara
there he does in the third round
I mean he's he even surpassing what you
were envisioning yes but the funny part
is rich you remember when we sat there I
said I know teams have first-round
grades on him he may not go there but
people have first-round grades on it and
just the way the draft fell and absolute
Steelers for Sean Payton and when he
drafted there we all said the same thing
oh my god he couldn't go to a better
team but he's surpassing what we saw
there's no doubt he's just unbelievable
he is it really is he couldn't get on
the field at Alabama because he's not
the right type of a back you know they
like those big thick bruisers that sort
of deal that wasn't his thing Tennessee
was a much better fit for him and of
course New Orleans is the best fit of
all so what do you think is gonna happen
now that Engram comes back how do you
solve does it don't go back and share
like they did rich they'll take some of
the pressure off of Alvin but Alvin will
continue to get lead carries lead
touches right now because he's the hot
hand
mm-hm but don't think for a second that
they're gonna try and out Lou you know
over working sean is very smart that way
the poll question of Charles Davis
Christopher Brockman go forward please
all right Charles looking at
quarterbacks here which quarterback
would you want for the next five years
Jared golf patrick mahomes mr. Biscay
deshaun Watson Carson went Romo choose
one
Holmes Wow and I know he's the hot
ticket right now I get it
he didn't stutter but here's the thing
when we evaluated him coming out
everything that we're seeing now was in
the evaluation what the concern was was
twofold and one of them is your team he
had a losing record as a starter that
can be you know you know how we can rate
that as a quarterbacks not like a
starting pitcher as much and the second
part is get so much confidence in his
arm they took a lot of chances in
college well he took a lot of chance in
college because of the score okay he's
continually battling back and trying to
make plays and we've seen him harness
that and that's one reason I really like
him obviously has the mobility to move
rowdy to get the big thick body
so what stand the withstand some of that
contact and I just think he's going to
continue to ascend I don't think we've
even scratched the surface so are you
saying that similar to the fact that my
golf game Charles that my best shot is
my knock down 5-iron to get out from
underneath the tree because I found
myself underneath the tree more than I
was in the fairway that Patrick mahomes
is suited for comebacks and throwing it
and making risky plays because he had to
more often than not in college is that
what you're saying Charles similar go go
go back and trace the time at Texas Tech
he's had to play in that spot been in
that spot many many times before so I
don't think that's going to faze him
like it might someone who came from a
program where things were a lot better
the team was better you didn't have as
much pressure in your face all of that
he's seen it all but the other part was
I think he did a really nice job last
year learning from Alex Smith and
learning from Andy Reid and and crew in
order to harness some of that because he
made some plays you can go back and find
him on tape with tech where he'd go
scrambling around and he throw across
his body back across field 50 yards and
sometimes it would work and sometimes it
wouldn't you're not seeing that with the
NFL game you've seen him really be smart
and judicious then when he turns it
loose
whoa - that whoa - the receiver who
doesn't have his hands up because this
coming hot all right Charles go hit that
B button wherever you want all right
okay you guys for calling it doctor you
rich Arabs up t in London I guess I will
see you soon
Charles Davis the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience